good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you're very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
inflation forecaster hit a 50-year high
of just over 18
in january causing more hardship for
millions of us charities warn that
rising prices will force people to make
choices between buying food and heating
their homes gas prices sold by 37
yesterday after russia said it would
shut down a critical pipeline to europe
for three days for maintenance energy
boss bill bollen is calling for the
conservative party to end its leadership
race and focus on the cost of living
instead we'll speak to him later on and
we'll ask government minister chloe
smith about the growing pressure on liz
trust to explain what she'll do to
support struggling families it's tuesday
the 23rd of august
forecasters warn that inflation is
entering the stratosphere driven by a
surging gas prices and rising energy
bills
police have launched a murder
investigation after a nine-year-old girl
is shot dead in liverpool
more misery for travellers i'm at
heathrow where british airways has
cancelled more than 10 000 flights from
its winter schedule
ukraine rejects ascu accusations by
moscow that it was behind a car bomb
that killed the daughter of one of
putin's close allies
dockers been men and barristers all out
on strike we'll be speaking to sharon
graham she's the boss of one of
britain's biggest unions about the wave
of industrial action
jeers turn to cheers at old trafford as
united inflict liverpool's first league
defeat of the year
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world
saving a cent to save alive the unusual
fragrance campaign to help sniffer dogs
find missing people
[Music]
and we'll hear from dj superstar paul
oakenfold who's played from ibiza to
everest base camp about how living with
dyslexia has shaped his life and his
career
[Music]
morning everybody inflation expected to
hit its highest level in nearly 50 years
experts warned that prices could rise by
18.6 in january which would leave
millions of families struggling to put
food on the table or heat their homes
the boss of one energy company is
calling on the conservative party to end
its leadership contest and focus on
dealing with the crisis we'll hear from
the government in just a moment
but first let's tell you about a
nine-year-old girl who has been shot
dead in liverpool merseyside police have
launched a murder investigation officers
were called to a house in kinship heath
avenue which is in the knotty ash area
of the city at ten o'clock last night
a statement from the police said they
were responding to reports that a man
had fired a gun inside a property the
child was shot in the chest and taken to
hospital in a critical condition where
she later died the force said a man also
suffered gunshot wounds to his body and
a woman suffered an injury to her hand
during the incident they've both been
taken to hospital the assistant chief
constable that's jenny sims described it
as a truly shocking incident in which
tragically a young and innocent girl has
been shot and sadly died she urged
anyone who knows anything to come
forward and speak to the police
and appealed for dash cam or mobile
phone footage from anyone who was
visiting i should say the area last
night we'll bring you more on that
incident as we get it
joined now by chloe smith minister of
state for disabled people work and
health hi good to see you thank you very
much indeed for joining us on the
program this morning here to talk about
a one-off disability payment of i think
150 pounds how far do you expect that to
go
can i first of all say how really sad
that news is from liverpool and and my
thoughts just go out to the the family
um
the
news we're talking about this morning is
really important actually to support
disabled people and it comes on top of
the uh whole package that the government
has put in place to support people on
the cost of living so actually in
totality what we're looking at is the
eight million most vulnerable households
in the country receiving at least 1200
pounds so all in all i hope this is of
serious help to people in the face of
rising pressures which of course the
government acknowledges how far do you
expect this 150 pounds to go well it
will make a contribution of course and
it comes on top of as i say the other
support as well so for example 400
pounds to all households on energy bills
so in the context of the kinds of costs
that disabled people face this i hope
will make a real contribution to what
people are facing the reason i'm asking
you minister is because we have spoken
to a young man a disabled man who
doesn't want to give his name for
obvious
reasons we spoke to him a week ago he
said he doesn't i'm quoting him does not
expect to be alive this spring because
of the scary cost of energy bills
well obviously i'm very sorry to hear
him say that and that's a very
concerning thing for somebody to say in
that context i would certainly hope that
all of the staff at job centres and in
other parts of the welfare system are
there to support him as they should be
and of course what a person may well be
eligible for
by means of this payment links to other
benefits that they would already be
getting so for example personal
independence payments or employment and
support equipment so there is of course
the breadth of the welfare system there
to support that particular person or
others in a similar
similar set of circumstances and what
the government is saying today is that
in addition to those normal parts of the
welfare system there is this support
available in terms of the cost of living
because we recognize those rising
pressures and it's important to have
acted which is what the government
is by january
these are very troubling figures and the
government agrees that these are very
worrying figures and that's why we're
acting with this package and of course
that's part of having acted already so
those who are on means-tested benefits
again for example employment and support
allowance will have received already
payments and that adds up to
over 1200 pounds
if inflation is at 19
by january let's try to you support is
still saying that a recession is not
necessarily inevitable she seems to be
the only person that's saying that at
the moment
well i don't think i don't think she's
she's alone in making the argument that
actually do you agree with her i do
agree with her because i do agree with
her because what we need to focus on
first of all is to be able to grow the
economy and she's been really clear that
that is her strategy and i think that's
right because growing the economy will
in turn raise tax receipts and that is
of course what enables us to run the
public services that will support the
person you've given the example of and
many others so i do agree with her
absolutely this is the right overall
strategy but i know that she is also
keenly aware of the pressures that
people are facing and that's why she
said she wouldn't rule out doing more
but she has to have the full data in her
hands but the tax cuts that she's
talking about will not benefit
the least well-off in this country
and that's why she said she wouldn't
rule out doing more but again she has to
have the full data in her hands if she's
lucky enough to become prime minister in
a few weeks time she would be able to
look at the entire picture and she said
that she would be putting forward an
emergency budget and that's where i
would expect those decisions to be made
um as far as an emergency budget is
concerned just looking at my notes here
um
she was reportedly planning that
emergency budget in september uh next
month um i think i'm right insane am i
writing saying that i believe so yeah
okay um the obr is giving an official
forecast the treasury committee chair
mel stride said she's flying blind
without having a forecast to work off
she doesn't want that or she's changing
her mind
i think to be fair uh okay you might be
trying to run several arguments at once
too because if you what would you like
to take from if you were to say that
inflation is rising as you as you did at
the beginning of this interview and
obviously we expect the price cap
information to come in this friday there
is already a building picture there what
liz has said on the obr point in
particular is that she wouldn't wish to
uh delay any further by waiting for that
so they're ready to go they're very
happy to she will she will have to be
able to be in position and take the data
that is available and within that
context she then wants to be able to
work as quickly as possible but the obr
have said that they will offer an
official forecast um and she's saying
she doesn't want one
is that right she she's saying she would
want to be able to use all the data that
is very available when she were to
become prime minister so you and i are
sitting here somewhat in advance of that
i would love liz trust to become prime
minister for reasons that i've been uh
very clear on and i think she has a
really clear plan and a bold vision but
she will have to have all of that data
available at that time then to be able
to make her decision tell me about her
bold vision what's she going to do to
help people
well in the context of the cost of
living of course she will be uh she will
be um continuing to support the actions
that the government has already taken
and much much more than that and in the
context of uh that and and the
information i'm bringing to you this
morning of course afresh is that the
disability payments the 150 pounds that
we began by talking about those will be
rolling out from the 20th of september
so i hope that that new information is
of uh some comfort to people that is
part of a plan that gets over 1200
pounds into the household into the
pockets of the households uh where most
vulnerable people live now that's really
important action in addition to that as
i've already mentioned uh liz trust if
she were to become prime minister has
said she has said that she doesn't rule
out further help uh for what that looks
like vulnerable i can't answer that for
you as you well know kate because that
would be the subject of her emergency
budget that's what people want to know
indeed they do and they will have to
keep watching your program and others as
the author they're not going to
necessarily vote for her are they unless
they know what she's watching liz has
already set out clearly is not enough
what liz has already set out very
clearly is that she wants to focus on
growing the economy and i think that's
actually really important also in the
context of the cost of living because
people do want to be able to have a job
in which they earn to be able to support
themselves and their households and liz
has spoken and i think rightly about
wanting to be able to focus on helping
people keep money in their pockets for
themselves rather than removing it in
taxes and returning it in bench and i
think that's perfectly okay what's she
going to do about the energy price cap
because quite a few energy bosses think
that it should be frozen and obviously
it's going to be looked at again and
soon and then also next january at least
three energy bosses that i could quote
to you know them already for actually um
are saying that the price uh should be
capped should be frozen um if they want
it surely she should want it
i'm aware of those arguments and indeed
for example also the labour party also
makes the argument that actually there
should be a
type of a freeze i worry that those are
short-term solutions only so i think
what we do not going to do i think what
we do need to look at is the longer-term
solutions about how to bring energy
prices down and there you need to think
about energy security and there you
would also need to think i think about
the ways that we uh interact with
somebody like vladimir putin of russia
whose actions have been a main part of
driving those prices up and driving
those pressures up now in elizabeth
trust you have somebody who's been i
think the clearest of all in saying that
we should stand up to uh putin uh for
the bully that he is but she's also been
clear that in other ways she will deal
with energy prices so for example
removing the levy that people pay and
that will take 150 pounds off bills now
on top of that she's also uh of course
going to be listening to the likes of
quasi quatern who has been working in
government already about further things
that can be chancellor potentially
that's for her to decide but this brings
me back to the main point she will she
would be in a position to make those
decisions if she became prime minister
so she's settling it out i certainly is
she ruling it out you've already heard
her say that she doesn't rule out
further support and i think that's right
now what i'm here to talk about this
morning is how we're supporting disabled
people with 150 pounds and that that is
coming on stream in september that is
really important and sits alongside the
opportunities for growth that we also
hope will benefit disabled people
because i was talking only last week
in studios
around
around the way that we're helping more
people into employment and that is vital
okay good to talk to you sadly we're out
of time it's great to see you thank you
very much indeed thank you and uh the
cost of living fills many of the front
pages again
this morning the financial times let's
start there reporting that gas prices
could be among the factors to propel
inflation beyond 18 next year the times
also leads on soaring inflation saying
it could hit a 50-year high while the
express asks how will millions cope if
prices keep on rising
and the i saying that liz trusts has
come under fire for backtracking on her
promise of an emergency budget if she
gets into number 10 instead of
downgrading to a so-called fiscal event
meantime let's turn to disruption at the
airports british airways has torn up its
winter schedule and cancelled 10 000
flights between late october
and march of next year maddie is at
heathrow airport for us this morning hi
maddie where will this all end
good morning kay who knows it feels like
that uh those flight cancellations which
have really blighted the summer holiday
period for so many are continuing and
will set look set to continue for months
now with this announcement from ba they
are cancelling some 629
short haul round trips from heathrow up
till the 29th of october that's
about 1 200 individual flights and then
making further changes to their winter
schedule up to march next year some
eight percent or 10 000 flights affected
there now ba say that they're giving
passengers plenty of notice here this
will allow them to prioritize that key
autumn half term getaway period
and while they have to comply with the
passenger cap that heathrow airport has
enforced 100 000 passengers a day that
is the cap heathrow airport has
introduced and extended just last week
until the end of october
any passengers affected will be offered
either the option of a refund or being
rebooked on another ba flight or
potentially with another airline but
that isn't going to be much consolation
for those looking at their uh travel
plans in autumn
good to talk to you thank you very much
indeed we'll be talking more about those
flights that have been cancelled and if
you are unlucky enough to be caught up
in that what you can and can't do to try
to get your money back and indeed
salvage your holiday that coming out
with simon calder a little bit later on
from the independent newspaper meantime
ukraine has rejected russian allegations
that it killed the daughter of one of
president vladimir putin's allies dario
was killed by a car bomb near moscow on
saturday her father was believed to have
been the target of the attack
let's talk about it in more detail ali
is standing by in odessa for us and as
we were saying yesterday um alistair it
is thought that her father who is often
described as putin's brain was supposed
to be the target of this attack
yeah i i think that is a logical
conclusion to come to uh because he was
we understand supposed to be traveling
in that car and it was only at the very
last minute that he decided to go
in a different vehicle and because he is
well known uh for
voicing a lot of the kremlin's thoughts
and influencing some of the kremlin's
decisions uh it would seem logical that
he was the target of that attack his
daughter was a pretty well known and
quite prominent uh journalist in russia
as well who um sympathised and echoed
with a lot of his thinking but i think
it probably is most likely that
he was the intended target russia opened
a murder investigation into his death
yesterday and then within a couple of
hours said that they had concluded that
it was ukraine that was behind the
attack they said that a ukrainian woman
had traveled to
moscow with her daughter carried out the
explosion remotely and then fled across
the estonian border now ukraine rejects
that out of hand
whatever the truth is i have to say it
would be a massive leap forward for the
ukrainians to be able to carry out an
operation like that uh right in the
center
of moscow but
vladimir putin has described the attack
as an evil attack and now there are
fears that they will want some sort of
retribution above and beyond
the normal daily shedding that goes on
here and the focus of that could be
tomorrow which is independence day marks
the point that uh ukraine got
independence from the soviet union but
also it marks the six month anniversary
of this war and the united states has
released some intelligence saying that
they are worried that the russians could
use tomorrow to launch some attacks
particularly on civilian and government
infrastructure kiev has banned all
celebrations related to independence day
as well to protect the civilians there
and there are some curfews around the
country as well
just before i let you go alistair we
were talking yesterday about grain
weren't we ships are starting to leave
odessa but not in the numbers that is
necessary at this stage
no i don't think so
it has been seen as a diplomatic success
getting this agreement between russia
and ukraine to allow cargo ships in and
out of there's about three ports around
odessa one you can see behind me and the
two sort of either side of it
and for sure it what it has done is it
has alleviated uh the problem to some
extent so because we're in harvest
season at the moment the great worry was
that the grain silos that were already
full just wouldn't be able to take any
more grain and so you would have a
ruined harvest this year but also the
inability to shift grain around the
world where it is desperately needed in
particular parts of africa and the
middle east so yeah the ships are coming
in we see them the whole time not enough
but you know better than it was
certainly and they are trying to get
them becoming more frequent and getting
around the world so
a very rare diplomatic success in this
war
but they could be doing more would be
the ideal situation okay thank you
still to come on the program for you we
will have more on the british airways
flight cancellations as i said speaking
to simon calder the travel journalist
about how to navigate through
thousands more flight cancellations this
winter
with barristers on strike over pay we'll
hear from one who says she earned more
money as a barista
later on speaking to founder of utility
energy bill bollam on how he's teaming
up with iceland to help people save
money
uh meantime some of today's other
headlines for you a host pipe ban has
been introduced in cornwall and parts of
devon today for the first time in 26
years southwest water says it's been
left with no other choice but to
implement the measure to preserve
supplies
lawyers of former u.s president donald
trump have asked a federal judge to stop
the fbi from reviewing documents
recovered during a search of his florida
home they want a neutral official
appointed to review the documents
concerned federal investigators are
looking into whether trump took the
materials illegally when he left office
in 2021
drug tests will finland's prime minister
have come back negative after a weekend
of dancing and partying she took the
tests voluntarily following criticism
from other politicians
just high on life there you go
aren't we all our report by tony blair's
foundation says gcses and a-levels
should be scrapped in favor of a new
system which better prepares school
leavers for the workplace the tony blair
institute for global change says
continuous forms of assessment between
the ages of 16 and 18 could replace the
current exams
okay let's return to the concert
conservative leadership race now joined
by the chair of the education select
committee and rishi sunak supporter
that's robert halfon hello to mr health
and thanks for joining us on the
programme we've been hearing from energy
companies over the last 24 hours they
want this leadership contest to end and
the new prime minister to con con um
concentrate i should say on what is
happening as far as the cost of living
crisis is concerned why doesn't your guy
just throw his hat into the uh
honestly i can't even speak this morning
i don't know what's going give up
basically throw the towel in that's the
phrase i was looking for
well the contest is is not over until
it's over there's only a less than a
couple of weeks to go before a new prime
minister uh is appointed uh there have
been different polls
polls of conservative councillors have
had wishy sunak and liz trust level
plaguing i think he's got an important
program for the country i'm supporting
him because i think he's trusted when
times were tough and we saw that with
the furlough scheme i think that he's
done a lot on the cost of living
providing
1200 pounds up to 1200 pounds for 8
million of the most vulnerable uh
families and i also support him because
of what he's saying on education about
having a british pclaudia more support
for vocational and technical education
and more free schools it may well be the
case but by any measure he's miles
behind in the contest and we have a cost
of living crisis where inflation could
be up to 18 by january it's all over for
him he just needs to accept that
i think that members have a right to
have a choice of who they would like to
have as prime ministers had a choice and
they've chosen liz trust it would appear
there's voting isn't over yet there's
some many many members who haven't yet
uh voted when she goes round the country
has a lot of support i mentioned the
poll of conservative councillors which
showed both candidates uh level playing
it's still all too uh playful be over
very uh shortly but you're absolutely
right
that cost of living is the number one
concern for
the nation and that's again why i'm
supporting rishi sunat because he says
we've got to cut inflation which is the
enemy of
the cost of living we've got to cut our
national debt because if the government
faces a triple whammy of public spending
pressures national uh debt and uh
helping with the cost of living and
you've got to deal with those things
first before you can have significant
tax cuts yeah and to do that you need to
be prime minister and the big beasts
sajid uh javid i'm looking at my list
penny mordant ben wallace nadeem zahawi
brandel lewis quasi quarten to raise
coffee they're all supporting the other
candidate
well big beasts like william hague
um nigel lawson
are in the cabinet
ranch chaps is in the cabinet stephen
bark is in the cabinet mark spencer is
in the uh cabinet but this is not just
about a level celebrities um or sorry a
celebrities who are
you know who support the
various leadership candidates about the
programme for uh the country and
i believe that wishy sunak has a
responsible program
in cutting the cost of living dealing
with the debt cutting inflation then
having a program towards uh income tax
cuts and and we will need major
interventions on the cost of living we
can't have
significant
tax cuts yet because of the pressures on
the public purse
if he cared
as you say about
the poorest in our society he would
acknowledge that the race is over and
fall in behind liz truss who by any
measure is miles ahead in the polls um
and accept that he's lost
i think it's right that the members have
a choice and i think wichita has shown
that he cares about the most
vulnerable he spent 37 billion pounds
when he was just chancellor just a few
months ago trying to help people get
through the cost of living a 400 pound
rebate for everyone on their energy
bills 1200 pounds for 8 million of the
most vulnerable families 150 pound
rebate in council tax most people a
national insurance tax cut in essence or
70 of households it's about what you do
and i think he is right um to be able to
have a chance uh to set his program not
just to the membership but to the the
country the contest will be over uh very
shortly i think it's right that members
have a choice it's still all to play for
haven't they had a choice so far
well the choice is that when
when when the membership votes and
they're voting at the moment not all the
members have voted there's still a
couple of weeks to go the candidates are
going around the country which is coming
to my own uh constituency uh in harlow
in a few in a few days meeting
members and that is the right thing to
do
um you are as i said chair of the
education select committee um
what do you make of the report by the
tony blair institute for global change
calling for the scrapping of gcse and a
levels
well i believe for some time that we
need to look at gcs dna levels but
particularly
a levels because we allow students to
narrow
at the age of 16 down to just three or
sometimes four four subjects i've been
to schools where they teach what is
called the international victoria where
they do a wide variety of subjects and i
think that is a much better system
for the world we're entering the world
of automation the world of artificial
intelligence i do think we need much
more skills-based education i'd like to
see more technical and vocational
education talk all the way through and
not have a dividing line between some
students doing vocational education and
some students doing academic it should
be a mixture of these of these things so
i think some things in the blair report
are well worth looking at but i should
note that rishi sunak we've been talking
about has also proposed a british
pclaudia
from the age of 16 where students would
do a much wider variety
of subjects including maths and english
all the way through until they've they
finished this their school yeah and if
i'd done my a levels i would have known
the difference between throwing your hat
in the ring and throwing in the towel
it's good to talk to you this morning
thank you very much indeed for joining
us on the program much appreciated thank
you
thank you
quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
unsettled and humid this week turning
very warm in the south but things should
settle down over the weekend mostly fine
and warm but there's fog and drizzle on
southwestern coast and hills
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now to an awful lot of money
disappearing between uh beneath the
waves i should say take a look at this
here we go a super yacht going down in
the med 40 meter long vessel run into
difficulty about 110 miles off the coast
of cantanzarro which is in southern
italy the italian coast guard rescued
all nine people on board four passengers
five crew but could do nothing to save
the vessel
goodness
have you ever watch below deck i'm a big
fan you'll know exactly what it was like
on that boat
um well from sinking ships to grounded
flights we'll be talking about british
airways after the break
[Music]
hello again everybody welcome back to
the program top stories for you this
morning government minister chloe smith
has told this program that she opposes
freezing the energy price cap insisting
that there needs to be a longer-term
solution to soaring energy costs
merseyside police have launched a murder
investigation after a nine-year-old girl
shot dead in liverpool two other people
have been wounded
british airways has cancelled 10 000
flights from its winter schedule between
late october and march of next year
[Music]
well earlier i was joined by the
government minister and liz trust
supporter chloe smith i asked her
whether miss trusts would support a
potential freeze on the energy price cap
as mentioned by some energy bosses
i'm aware of those arguments and indeed
for example so the labour party also
makes the argument that actually there
should be a
type of a freeze i worry that those are
short-term solutions only so i think
what we do not going to do i think what
we do need to look at is the longer term
solutions about how to bring energy
prices down and there you need to think
about energy security and there you
would also need to think i think about
the ways that we uh interact with
somebody like vladimir putin of russia
whose actions have been a main part of
driving those prices up and driving
those pressures up
tamar is here with us this morning as
always of course good morning to you
what did you make of what the minister
had to say well liz trust is being
pressed again and again and again kay on
what help she's going to offer people
with bills in the short term because of
course while it's important that the
west wings itself off russian gas and
potentially builds more nuclear power
stations and all the other measures it's
important that people who are facing
energy bills four thousand pounds in
january in just a few months time get
help with that now chloe smith the
minister for disabled people is talking
about 150 pound payment announced under
the current government in may which
people will be getting soon but the
problem is much of this support that was
put together in may was intended for
energy bills to reach about 2 800 pounds
they're gonna get a lot higher than that
and we'll get a sense of that when we
hear the cap on friday and yet as she
said when you said what is liz trust
offering people in terms of immediate
support she said i can't tell you that
you'll have to wait till september when
and if she is prime minister so she's
still not wanting to set out what that
would be just saying she wants to
prioritize tax cuts and i thought there
was an admission there when you said to
her but they will only they will help
people who are better off more than
those at the bottom of the pile and
admitting that that was the case saying
yes we may offer other support as well
we just can't tell you what it is yeah
and guidance um from the obr doesn't
look that's right so um the office for
budget responsibility is of the
independent watchdog set up by george
osborne every budget and autumn
statement they prepare a forecast saying
this is how much the economy is growing
this is how much money essentially you
have to play with and they can also do
them at other times in fact when i spoke
to the obr yesterday they said if the
new prime minister and chancellor want
to forecast we can prepare them one for
what liz trust was calling her emergency
budget in september now the trust team
don't want one they'd initially
suggested it might take too long to
prepare after the obr said they could
prepare it quickly they suggested that
they didn't need it because it wasn't a
proper budget and they're now calling it
something else calling it a fiscal event
so even though it's going to be quite
massive we're talking about reversing
the national insurance rise this is
billions and billions of pounds and it
sounds like they don't want the
up-to-date numbers and the accusation
from the cnet camp is that they don't
want to know how much the public
finances have deteriorated since we last
saw these charts back in march i wonder
what a budget is if it's not a fiscal
event
well she's trying to draw this
distinction between a proper budget
which we still expect to have in
november and what she's doing now
something more targeted but the fact
that she doesn't want to have the
forecast suggests that um according to
her critics she may not want to know
what's in them perhaps the biggest hint
yet that quasi qatang is looking at the
chancellor's job but we'll see
we've got tomorrow's take at nine
o'clock see you then look forward to it
thank you
british airways has announced it's
cancelling up to 10 000 flights this
winter and concerns are growing that
other airlines will also announce mass
cancellations joined now by the travel
correspondent of the independent that's
simon calder's travel editor of course
for give me that assignment um
talk to me in more detail about what on
earth is going on with the british
airways and i'm guessing with other
airlines as well
well british airways by far the biggest
carrier at uh london heath rowe has
announced or well they told the trade
first their agents and holiday companies
and so on they said right we are going
to be taking out yet more flights this
winter now you'll recall that um at the
start of the summer season that was the
end of march all the airlines had great
plans for the summer for example easyjet
said it was going to have its biggest
ever program from gatwick that soon fell
apart and they uh have cancelled
thousands of flights british airways
which was getting back to pre-covered
levels at heathrow has so far cancelled
about 30 000 flights um there's another
1
250 uh just been announced in the next
couple of months which will take us to
the end of the summer season
then in the winter the pressure should
be off cancelling ten thousand short
haul domestic and
european flights and uh that represents
um along with the
flights which are being taken out long
haul as well fewer of those a few
hundred of those represents about two
million seats taken out of the market
now you might think well that's great
for the environment and um undoubtedly
it is but if you're a terror if you're a
passenger it could be bad news
yeah absolutely so what can you do what
are your rights
well if you're affected and the whole
idea by of making these cancellations
now is that um actually many of the
flights won't have that many people
booked on them um it's very
straightforward you could get a a refund
but of course the vast majority of
people are actually going to want to
travel where they want to go when they
want to get there
and therefore british airways will put
you on one of its other flights and
in general most of the cuts are going to
be on routes where there are more than
one flight a day so they can just switch
you to another flight um if for some
reason there isn't another ba flight
available then they have to put you on a
different airline um but the impact is
going to be felt
disproportionately i fear kay on the
domestic route so that's from belfast
city from aberdeen inverness glasgow
edinburgh newcastle and manchester
those are flights which typically have
lots of people connecting and i was just
taking a look at what the cuts mean so a
month today going from london heathrow
to aberdeen where you'd normally expect
six or eight flights a day from first
thing in the morning till uh last thing
at night there are just two they're both
in the evening and the lowest price at
this stage is 215 pounds whereas
normally you'd expect to be able to pick
something up for less than half that and
it's people in the regions of the uk who
i think are going to be most affected
and you could find that yeah you've got
a connecting flight from heath row but
you're actually going to be hanging
around um for many hours because the
flight you were on has been pruned
up yeah what about if you're flying long
hall um are those less likely to be
impacted
yeah i mean that's where british airways
makes the vast majority of its money and
they will always protect the long-haul
schedule there have been some cuts so
for example there's multiple flights
every day to new york and certainly on
some quiet days they will they will fill
it a few of those um and that probably
won't mean more than an hour or two uh
difference between what you were
planning to do important to say that um
at this stage doesn't look like
anybody's going to be getting any cash
compensation because they are aiming to
give at least two weeks notice of these
changes which means they are not liable
to pay out
any compensation
uh for the inconvenience um but
honestly the amount of capacity that's
being taken out means that
anybody who is looking to travel will
find that there is less choice and that
uh prices are higher both on british
airways itself and of course on the
competitors easyjet and ryanair uh
picking up bookings all over the place
because british airways um uh is culling
so many flights but ba itself isn't
losing out that much because overall
price levels are going through the roof
uh to get here to italy i pay 300 pounds
which is roughly three times what i
would have liked to have paid oh well at
least you're in italy enjoy it while you
can it's good to talk to you thank you
now in a fortnight's time we'll know
who's to become the next leader of the
conservative party and thus the new
prime minister of the united kingdom liz
trusts and rishi sunak head to
birmingham today as they aim to put the
manifestos to tory members in the
midlands so what are the latest polls
saying well in the studio political
commentator and former president of yugo
peter kellner it's great to see you as
always thanks very much indeed for
joining us let's talk about the big lead
for labour to start with we had a yougov
poll at the weekend which showed a labor
lead of 15 percentage points over the
conservatives the biggest nearly 10
years if that were the election results
labor would not just win they would have
a fairly comfortable overall majority
but whenever i see a single pole showing
a sudden change i say is this real or is
it a sampling fluke we've had two more
polls since that yuga poll opinion
sunday's observer and redfield and
wilson out this morning they disagree on
the raw figures but they agree
absolutely that labour's leaders shot up
by five or six points in the last week
or two so in three polls by different
companies slightly different methods all
agree on the direction of travel i think
we can take it as real okay so this hugo
poll at the weekend gave labour 43
points the conservatives um down on 28th
and the lib dem is 11.
yeah um and remember at the last general
election the conservatives run 45
across britain so they're now down 17
points they've lost a third of their
support um
they are in i think very very deep
trouble i think when we talked to some
weeks ago i think i predicted that there
would be a honeymoon for the new tory
prime minister i'm not quite so sure
that'll happen the conservative
leadership campaign i think has done the
party quite a lot of harm and that's
part of what we're seeing here i hadn't
really seen a supporter on the program
just a few moments ago and he was saying
it isn't all over he's still uh in the
running is he
uh no
right but he would say that wouldn't he
exactly that's what i thought uh talk to
me about labour's proposal for freezing
energy bills how's that looking
well here i i mean you've got something
quite remarkable happening you've got
the labour's policy of freezing um bills
you have tested this amongst the general
public last week and found overwhelming
support for it with 69
saying it's a good idea just 13
saying it's a bad idea now you you do
occasionally get that sort of division
but i can't remember the last time on a
big controversial policy where leading
members of one political party are on
one side and the other party on the
other side i don't remember a figure
that's one-sided and i'm sure that's
part of the reason why labour's leader
has been going up
um yeah i mean that that proposition by
labour means that everybody will benefit
it's not just uh the worse off so yeah
it's interesting you can make so many
you can make a lot of comments or
criticisms about it whether it'll
that's right but but but for the moment
it has clearly caught the public's
imagination and even conservative
supporters overwhelmingly think it's a
good idea if i will lose trust i'd be
quite worried
that unless she can trump that with a
policy that has even greater appeal she
will look as if she's lagging behind
labor on catching the public we had a
list trust supporter on the program
earlier on uh this morning and it didn't
look as though they were going to adopt
that certainly for now um but who knows
she's been known to u-turn before who
would you vote for as tory leader was a
question that was asked as well um
that's right well
the ghosts of of of boris johnson as we
hanging over this conte contest so when
you go up last week polls tory party
members specifically specifically
supposing boris johnson were in the race
along with liz truss um and richie sunak
who would you vote for and if you look
at the figures you see that boris
johnson comes out miles ahead uh 46
percent for boris johnson uh
there you see 46. that's what seller's
remorse looks like
it does and are signs from from other
polls that um both amongst party members
and perhaps now more importantly as we
move forward amongst the general public
this trust some of the shine is becoming
coming off this trustee's reputation um
opinion poll on on sunday should amongst
the public a couple of weeks ago uh liz
truss outranked here starman's best
prime minister naoki astama has moved
into the lead over her that's why i'm
not quite so sure she'll get a honeymoon
periods of course in the long run
how she performs as prime minister will
determine it not my reputation after the
first few weeks but she's she's entering
some trickier waters than i think we all
expected a month or six years 18
inflation by january potentially um why
the public where does boyce johnson sit
there
well now here's the thing that um when
you
when you ask a standard question do you
approve or disapprove of boris johnson
as prime minister this was an opinion
survey over the weekend
boris johnson's ratings are pretty
terrible just a quarter of the public
think he's uh approve of his uh role as
prime minister well over half
disapprove
and here's the thing we saw that the
conservative support is down to 30 you
will take a point or two they've got to
get back up to well over 40 to win the
next election a lot of the people who've
deserted the conservatives are people
who feel let down by boris johnson's
personality and performance and policies
over the last couple of years so if this
trust is appealing to the conservative
activists she'll talk up by johnson say
how much of a fan she is of his because
party members love him but she's trying
to win back those lost voters three four
million lost voters they're not people
who like boris johnson so if she goes
all pro johnson as prime minister i
think it will make it harder for her to
win back those three or four million
votes she needs always great to see you
thanks very much indeed for joining us
thank you
now manchester united the former kings
of english football kicked off again
against liverpool last night bottom of
the table and on zero
thousands of fans had gathered outside
old trafford to protest demanding the
club's owners give up control none of
them expected what happened next here's
rob
[Applause]
old trafford and red devils fans are
raging
marching on their stadium in a show of
descent
the love for their club is enduring the
loathing has so long around here is
targeted at manchester united's owners
the glazers blame for the nine years
without winning the premier league and
five years without any trophy at all
the visit of liverpool one of united's
biggest rivals uses the platform of
protest after starting the league with
back-to-back defeats
the unveiling of another signing not
enough to dampen the anger
60 million pound midfielder casimiro a
30 year old arriving from real madrid
not at his peak
the club in the alex ferguson heyday had
no debt before the glazers takeover now
it's nearly 600 million pounds
servicing the debt has cost more than a
billion pounds in 17 years
there has been over 1.1 billion pounds
spent net on transfers
the fans chanting outside old trafford
missed the drama inside the stadium
cristiano ronaldo dropped from the
starting lineup his replacement though
coming so close to grabbing the opener
it wasn't long before united did take
the lead for the first time this season
still
sancho everything was going right for
once for united marcus rashford
mohamed salah ensured a nervy conclusion
for united but too little too late for
liverpool
eric tenharg the fifth full-time manager
since ferguson finally has his first win
as united manager
how fortunes can change in 90 minutes
now it's liverpool the team still
without a win after three matches and
the united faithful who arrived here at
old trafford protesting today leave
celebrating the players but certainly
not the owners
we love united but we want glazers out
if you've got a failing business it's
always the boss
that needs to get the brunt of
everything rather than the players i
know the players haven't been that great
i think we have the right players on the
pitch tonight that's my point of view
good win but it doesn't oversee the
protest really then we need to get rid
of him but i was expecting us to get
smashed but luckily we didn't
the hope is not only the silverware
returns but that the glazers aren't the
owners celebrating here too
rob harris sky news old trafford
[Applause]
just remind me who's top of the league
oh yeah the arsenal criminal barristers
in england and wales have voted in
favour of an all-out strike in their
deepening dispute with the government
over jobs and pay let's show you part of
what this dispute is all about here we
see the pace scale here we go ranging
from very junior barristers right up to
the most experienced
so at the top end of the scale
barristers with up to 27 years
experience earned more than 97 000
pounds per year compare that with
barristers who are just starting out
they make less than 13 000 pounds a year
joining us now is rosalind bergin she's
their junior barrister at garden court
north chambers hello to rosalind thanks
for joining us what kind of disruption
will this strike which is kicking in
from the 5th of september have on the
court process
yes well um we've been on a on and off
strike for much of the year starting in
april um but as negotiations the
government refuses to to budge on their
nonsensical offer we're now escalating
to all-out strikes so that is
no attendance at criminal defense crown
court trials
so what what impact will that actually
have on the court system what does that
mean if um a trial that was due to you
know that somebody's waited two years
for a trial to come up it will just be
postponed indefinitely or what happens
yes yes that's completely right when we
can't attend court until something is
done to address the crisis it's
incredibly painful i mean i
when i i fully fully support the ballot
i fully support the strike action but i
felt sick reading the result yesterday
because yeah i think of my clients who
are
going to you know going to delay even
further as a result of the strike but
we didn't create that crisis we didn't
create that situation
we're striking because we're out of
other options to address it
yeah but some i mean you you touch on it
there some of these cases are victims of
let's say violent crime how
how must they be feeling knowing that
their justice or the hope of justice may
be indefinitely delayed
well you know i interact with these
people on a daily basis um these they're
not abstract concepts to me i'm very
close to these people
and
i mean the backlog was 41 000 in march
2020 pre-pandemic the backlog is 58 000
in july 2022. that was already the case
and that's why we're striking um i went
to court yesterday it was in a civil
case it wasn't in a criminal case so it
wasn't someone that's that's been
affected by the strikes but still
someone very vulnerable waiting for
justice someone accused of something
who's maintaining their innocence i
turned up and said good morning and he
said what are you doing here you should
be on strike because he fully supports
what we're doing because people who
experience the criminal justice system
want someone to represent them who's
able to do the job and being able to do
the job means being paid means not
having to take on a crazy amount of
workload so to answer your question
it's for those people that we're
striking not not despite of them they're
the motivation certainly for me and i
know for a lot of my colleagues
um
not what the justice secretary would be
saying he's written uh to the daily mail
today being very critical of barristers
yes i'm sure he has
what we're trying to do
is
raise the alarm and
do something about the crisis that has
been long running in the criminal
justice system
our demands are
pretty modest in the context of the cuts
that the criminal justice system has
faced um if if there are any other
alternatives for the court backlog
i'd be keen to hear them but at the
moment the government has just not given
anything back
if you can hear them if you can get
through to them to get any kind of
breakdown of why they think their offer
is justifiable then you'll be doing
better than ours
um
the
the next as you said you've been on
strike on and off for most of the year
but this big strike is uh from the fifth
of september now there is also another
event happening on the 5th of september
as my viewers will know is when we find
out who our new prime minister will be
um have you chosen that date
specifically
um i i can't say sorry i'm not that not
as far as i'm aware um but i do think
this upheaval in government is a good
opportunity for new leadership to come
in and just get this over with just
finish this there's been a legacy of
cuts a decimation of the criminal
justice system if this this government
keeps saying it's tough on law and order
we've got an average of 700 days delay
for trials 1500 days delay for sexual
assault cases
what are they doing um i think it would
be a very smart move of any new leader
of any party coming in to resolve this
on day one the cost
in proportion is not that much we're
asking for i think less of an investment
than what the government has made in
selling off the court state in the last
last decade it's really would be very
easy and very quick to fix so i hope
this government turmoil leads to whoever
comes in next just sorting this out
straight away nice easy win as soon as
they start
just remind us what you want
so our demands are for an increase to
the advocates fees so that's our
barrister's fees that we get per case by
25
for claims submitted on or after 11th of
april 2022. so i mean this is in the
context of a 28 cut in our income over
the past 16 years so
we're still asking for less than what it
has been cut by um we're also asking for
paper written work as recommended by the
independent review index linking and
independent pay review body require um
as similar to what mps have they're the
demands the government keeps saying that
they've offered us a 15
pay rise i really wish it would stop
getting reported without question that
that's what they've offered because it's
just not true
the um offer let's have a look at it it
will come in unfortunately we can't
unpack it right now because we are out
of time but we have done that previously
on the programme and i'm sure we will do
it again it's great to talk to you thank
you very much indeed for joining us
thank you
thank you thank you
coming up in just a few moments time
we're going to be taking you back to
liverpool where a young girl has been
shot dead overnight two adults um
are seriously ill in hospital it's
thought to have been within a property
in this street in liverpool in
nottinghash the little one was just nine
years old the latest on that coming up
in just a few moments time also we are
going to be talking about the cost of
living crisis the latest scary figures
for us are 18
inflation by january
goodness stay tuned
[Music]